if you go look at tick tock accounts of  15 16 17 year olds you have 16 year olds  that have in their bio investor and i'm  like this is profound what i'm seeing is  a bigger convo the rise of people saying  i'm an investor too and then the rise of  what they want to invest in so now  you've got 15 to 30 year olds that think  about investing but they don't want to  buy a one family bedroom and make  recurring revenue on rent they want to  buy a pair of nikes that are going to go  up 2x they want to buy john marant  rookie cards they want the nft to put in  their social media profile and they want  it to go up that's very different than  buying 75 shares of turner because  investing is now more pop culture and  fashion everyone now sees it as a viable  cultural thing you do and they just are  going to do it in new stuff so  alternative investments that is a big  deal and it hasn't begun